de la fumée s'échappe encore de cette
immeuble le bâtiment vient d'être touché
balayé par une frappe russe en plein
cœur de Cardiff deuxième ville du crâne
les secouristes s'affairent à la
recherche d'éventuelles survivants au
milieu des décombres cette femme une
habitante de l'immeuble miraculé
j'étais dans mon lit je réfléchissais
encore et encore soudain quelque chose
de très puissant m'a emporter je suis
sortie du lit j'étais directement dans
la cuisine je ne sais pas comment je
suis encore en vie les autorités locales
font état d'au moins un mort et
plusieurs blessés déjà ce dimanche les
frapperus avaient fait des victimes 3 au
moins ici à Herson selon les autorités
ukrainiennes qui ajoute qu'une école un
hôpital aurait aussi été pris pour cible
rerson cette ville abandonnée par
l'armée russe en novembre dernier est à
nouveau l'objet de bombardements
réguliers
aujourd'hui oui c'est très intense il y
a beaucoup de bombardements
j'étais à une demi-heure de marche du
marché central et j'ai entendu trois ou
quatre buts voler
de son côté l'administration rue sans
place au sud de la région de zaporigia
rapporte qu'une frappe ukrainienne
visant un pont ferroviaire aurait fait
plusieurs victimes dans cette région les
combats acharnés ont bel et bien repris
ces derniers jours